[Música]
Hola Yo soy Natalia Cabrera parada y
esto es aquí América este es el programa
de France 24 para revisar en profundidad
las historias de nuestro continente y
esto es lo que veremos hoy
el obispo nicaragüense Rolando Álvarez
se niega al destierro y sigue en prisión
por criticar a Daniel Ortega que a su
vez arrecia la persecución al modificar
la Constitución para que la policía
actúe en defensa del statu quo y vamos a
ir a Brasil donde miles de afganos
encontraron una segunda oportunidad
desde el regreso del régimen talibán al
poder miles han llegado al aeropuerto de
San Pablo donde las autoridades no dan
abasto y visitamos también Perú cuya
gastronomía es reconocida a nivel
mundial por su exquisitez recientemente
un restaurante de Lima fue elegido como
el mejor del planeta los peruanos tienen
un día nacional para conmemorar el
ceviche un plato hecho a partir de
pescado fresco les contamos las claves
para prepararlo
y vamos a ir de inmediato a Nicaragua
para revisar la imagen de la semana el
obispo Rolando Álvarez se negó a hacer
desterrado y permanece detenido en una
cárcel de Managua tras haber sido
condenado sin juicio por supuesta
traición a la patria Daniel Ortega
intentó esta semana deshacerse del
impacto que tiene en su popularidad el
hecho de tener un religioso en prisión
Pues según una encuesta de galup para el
medio confidencial el 79% de los
nicaragüenses rechaza el arresto de
Álvarez por lo que Ortega intentó
negociar con el Vaticano su Liberación
Álvarez ha reiterado que no renunciará a
su nacionalidad solo por ser crítico con
el régimen de Ortega en sus eucaristías
ya en febrero de 2022 Álvarez se había
negado al destierro cuando Ortega envió
a 222 presos políticos a Estados Unidos
escuchemos lo que decía antes de su
arresto es lo que pasa es que
el gobierno siempre
una iglesia muda no quiere que hablemos
no quiere que anunciemos la esperanza al
pueblo ni denunciemos la injusticia Y
entonces obviamente yo pienso que
quieren acallar la voz de la iglesia
pues verdad Pero si nosotros callamos
las piedras van a gritar y Es que desde
que el Papa Francisco calificó al
gobierno nicaragüense como una dictadura
Ortega rompió relaciones diplomáticas
con el Vaticano y arreció su cerco a la
iglesia católica prohibiendo las
procesiones de semana santa y expulsando
monjas del país Así hablo Francisco en
una entrevista ahí tenemos un Obispo
preso
un hombre muy serio muy capaz
y sobre su testimonio y no no aceptó el
exilio fuera de lo que estamos viviendo
como si fuera a traer
de dictaduras
del 17 comunistas o hitlerianas del 35
están las aquí las mismas
un tipo de dictaduras
groseras
y Esto justamente nos lleva a la cifra
de la semana además de Álvarez Son 64
personas las que siguen detenidas por
motivos políticos en Nicaragua según el
mecanismo para el reconocimiento de
personas presas políticas una iniciativa
de Defensores de Derechos Humanos que
trabaja desde la crisis de 2018 en la
que las protestas contra Ortega y contra
su esposa fueron duramente reprimidas
dejando un saldo de 355 fallecidos según
la Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos
[Música]
y esta semana Ortega tomó otro paso en
dirección a la represión y pidió a la
asamblea nacional controlada
completamente por sus partidarios
modificar la Constitución que establecía
que la policía era una institución a
política y a partidista y la subordinó a
la presidencia y además agregó el delito
de deserción El hecho ocurre luego de
que decenas de policía huyeron a Estados
Unidos y a Costa Rica el caso más
reciente es el de la subcomisionada
María de Jesús Guzmán quien llegó a la
Unión Americana la semana pasada la
policía nicaragüense nació en 1979 con
el nombre de policías andinista y ha
sido una institución clave para Ortega
desde su regreso al poder en 2007 es
común que los uniformados participen en
eventos políticos en 2020 la Casa Blanca
sancionó a la institución y a sus
dirigentes por violaciones a los
derechos humanos en el marco de las
protestas antigubernamentales de 2018
y cambiamos de tema y nos vamos a Brasil
que ha emitido 11.500 visados
humanitarios para ciudadanos de
Afganistán desde el regreso del talibán
al poder la mayoría de ellos llegaron al
aeropuerto de San Pablo Pero a pesar de
lo magnánimo del programa las
autoridades no lo pueden gestionar de
manera fluida debido a la cantidad de
personas que llegan en el Aeropuerto
Internacional de esta ciudad se forman
aglomeraciones que el gobierno de Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva atiende con
traslados periódicos veamos el informe
del equipo de France 24 en terreno
previo a un traslado reciente
llevan desde las seis de la mañana
preparando comida para unos 200
refugiados afganos que están acampados
en el aeropuerto a la espera de una
plaza en una casa de acogida
unas 15 personas se encargan de la
logística para que esta comida llegue
caliente al Aeropuerto Internacional de
San Pablo que Lidia con una emergencia
humanitaria desde febrero de 2022
toda la entrega tiene que ser muy rápida
para disminuir el riesgo de
contaminación
la situación es crítica nos piden
ocultar el rostro de estos refugiados
por seguridad
muchos afganos llevan semanas sin
ducharse incluso denuncian una Plaga de
sarna
[Música]
Este joven llegó Hace seis meses huyendo
de la persecución de los talibanes aquí
creó una ong para ayudar a sus
compatriotas en Afganistán también
trabajaba en la defensa de los Derechos
Humanos no hay suficientes campos de
refugiados para alojar a todo el mundo
Este es un problema enorme cada día
llegan más afganos y la aglomeración
aquí sigue creciendo ahora mismo tenemos
a 205 afganos pero mañana pueden llegar
a ser 250 el día después 300 o 400 sin
embargo las autoridades no toman una
actitud para llevar a todo el mundo a un
albergue desde el ayuntamiento de
guarullios exigen más apoyo del gobierno
central para gestionar esta crisis
humanitaria hasta la fecha Han atendido
a más de 3.500 afganos
hoy el estado de Sao Paulo tiene cerca
de 800 plazas en los albergues durante
meses conseguimos acoger a estas
personas Pero todas las plazas se
llenaron por eso los refugiados
volvieron a aglomerarse en el aeropuerto
el municipio de guarullios ya hizo
varias peticiones al Gobierno Federal
una de ellas es la interiorización de
estas personas en todo el país Brasil
tiene capacidad para recibir a estos
refugiados
se refiere al programa implementado en
Brasil Para repartir a los refugiados
venezolanos en otros estados el gobierno
central ha prometido trasladar a los
afganos hacinados en el aeropuerto
albergues de ciudades cercanas
y esta semana tuvieron lugar dos cumbres
de líderes de países de la región la del
mercosur y la de la comunidad del Caribe
California vamos a revisar cada una de
ellas el mercosur Argentina Brasil
Uruguay y Paraguay se dio cita en Puerto
iguazú con el tratado de libre comercio
con la Unión Europea y la crisis en
Venezuela en la agenda por un lado el
acuerdo firmado en 2019 sigue sin
implementarse debido a exigencias del
Antiguo continente en materia
medioambiental que son criticadas por
Brasil y Argentina que denuncian que
dejan a Suramérica relegada a un papel
de exportador de materias primas las
diferencias se hicieron evidentes con la
decisión del presidente uruguayo Luis
lacalle púa de no firmar la declaración
final pues quiere acelerar un tratado de
libre comercio con china que está
bloqueado precisamente por la posición
de Lula y de Alberto Fernández y por
otro lado los presidentes uruguayo y
paraguayo Mario abdo Benítez se unieron
para pedir el rechazo en bloque a la
inhabilitación de la opositora
venezolana María Corina Machado a
participar en las elecciones
presidenciales en Venezuela en 2024
recordemos que Brasil y Argentina han
sido Aliados del régimen venezolano
desde tiempos de Hugo Chávez escuchemos
los momentos destacados del encuentro de
mandatarios al que asistió Además Luis
Arce de Bolivia que se encuentra en
proceso de adhesión al mercosur
es imperativo que mercosur provea un
cambio y una respuesta fuerte
entregar el poder de compra del Estado
uno de los pocos instrumentos de
política Industrial que nos quedan
notemos intereses no nos interesan
acuerdos que nos condenen al eterno rol
de exportadores de materia prima
minerales y crudos
flaco favor le haríamos a la democracia
venezolana y al pueblo venezolano sino
alzamos nuestra voz Como hizo el
presidente abdo que suscribo apoyo y en
este tono como es el que siempre tenemos
creo que el mercosur tiene que dar una
señal clara para que el pueblo
venezolano pueda
encaminarse a una democracia plena que
claramente hoy no la tiene entre tanto
Los jefes de estado y de gobierno de la
comunidad del Caribe caricom celebraron
sus 50 años en Trinidad y Tobago y como
regalo se dieron la libre circulación de
sus ciudadanos para vivir y trabajar en
cualquiera de las naciones que la
integran el tema clave de la agenda sin
embargo fue Haití que está sumido en una
profunda crisis política y social y
asediado por la violencia de las
pandillas en el marco de este encuentro
el secretario de estado de Estados
Unidos Anthony blinquen se reunió con el
Primer Ministro de Haití Ariel Enrique y
apoyó el envío de una fuerza especial
estadounidense a la isla según la ONU
más de dos mil personas fueron
asesinadas y más de 1.300 secuestradas
en 2022 por las pandillas más del doble
que en 2021
el trabajo que estamos haciendo para
fortalecer a la policía y los servicios
de seguridad en Haití tiene tiempo para
verse reflejado y que el gobierno pueda
retomar el control del país y no ser
dominado como lo está ahora en tantos
lugares por las pandillas
y nos vamos a Perú que celebró el Día
Nacional del ceviche una fiesta para
conmemorar a uno de los principales
platos de la gastronomía del país
suramericano Francisco Zacarías nos
cuentan las claves para lograr un buen
ceviche peruano
el ceviche es uno de los máximos
exponentes de la gastronomía del Perú
porque enlaza la gran diversidad
culinaria de esta nación andina es un
plato de orgullo para millones de
peruanos quienes con mucha emoción
participan de los festejos Trozos de
pescado fresco jugo de limón ají sal y
pimienta al gusto finas rodajas de
cebolla roja junto a pedazos de batata y
maíz tierno son las principales
ingredientes por sus intensos Sabores y
la combinación de productos autóctonos
traspasó fronteras y ha conquistado los
paladares más exigentes es la imagen de
nuestra cocina peruana son tiempos en
que el mundo está puesto los ojos en el
Perú mediante nuestra cocina reconocida
como una de las mejores del mundo porque
el ceviche es la imagen del Perú
y es un plato que se consume cuando uno
está en un estado de alegría Feliz y
esto es una muestra Perú vive una fiesta
gastronómica los principales chefs de
diversas regiones del país demuestran
sus habilidades para preparar un buen
ceviche también se realizan
degustaciones y campeonatos de maestros
cevicheros mira todo es al instante como
ustedes ven estamos estamos preparando
todo al instante todos el momento y
todos los insumos frescos importante
tener un buen pescado fresco la cebolla
también al instante todo tiene que estar
fresquito para que salga bien un buen
ceviche Eso es lo importante y un buen
limón por supuesto desde de un limón del
Norte del país que es de piura no
el gobierno peruano busca que el ceviche
que se prepare en este país sea
declarado patrimonio cultural de la
UNESCO con esa finalidad el Ministerio
de cultura presentó un expediente al
organismo para Resaltar la labor de
pescadores productores agrícolas y
cocineros tradicionales de esta nación
la UNESCO dará a conocer la decisión en
diciembre en Botswana África y
África Gracias Francisco y gracias a
ustedes por ver aquí América en la
producción estuvo Giovanni agudelo por
favor envíenme sus comentarios en la
dirección que ven en su pantalla Sigan
viendo France 24
[Música]